regarde Nitro ce que je t'ai préparé mon
chien adore se plantent ils en ont tous
les matins dès potron-minet comme on dit
un chat qui mange de l'herbe comme les
vaches bizarre rassurez-vous Nitro va
très bien mon chat ne souffre pas d'un
dédoublement de la personnalité je vais
vous montrer
[Musique]
la petite caméra l'a filmé en cachette
elle a l'air de se régaler c'est un
comportement largement répandu chez les
chats d'après les études pour 70 %
d'entre consomme de l'herbe sur plante
porte d'ailleurs un nom qui évoque 7
appétence il y a l'air bon chat et
l'herbe à chat vous connaissez la
différence entre les deux vous donnez
votre nouveau chat je vais vous montrer
et j'ai tout ça dans le jardin
ça c'est une herbe aux chats de Kater on
dit aussi une menthe à chat c'est vrai
que tu ressembles
et ça sent un peu la menthe
les chats ne font pas de dents il
renifle cette plante un effet
euphorisant sur souvent il se roule par
terre court et saute dans tous les sens
après avoir mis le nez de pense que la
cataire produit des molécules qui
ressemble au phéromone sexuel du chat
douleur comportement à leur présence si
vous n'avez vous pouvez malgré tout
implanté sur votre balcon ou dans votre
jardin et la cataire produit de jolies
fleurs c'est une plante mellifère qui
comme son nom l'indique attire les
abeilles photos de chats dans le
quartier
plus classique la fameuse herbe à chat
ce sont des jeunes pousses de graminées
du blé de l'orge ou de l'avoine fait ni
trop adore mâchouiller et ce n'est pas
parce qu'on dit graminées que les chats
qui en consomme sont plus grands que les
autres en fait on ne sais pas vraiment
pourquoi les chats mangent de l'herbe
même si on en fait tout un foie
pendant longtemps on a pensé que l'herbe
et des le chat régurgiter pour faciliter
l'évacuation des poils et des plumes qui
Laval en même temps que c'est toi ou
même c'est propre poil enfin c'est pour
les salles quand il fait sa toilette un
peu finalement comme le font les
chouettes et les hiboux qui regurgite
des pelotes dans lesquelles retrouve des
poils des plumes et les petits hauts de
leur proie seulement voilà une étude
réalisée en 2017 sur plus de 1000 chats
à montrer que seulement 30 % des chats
qui consomme de l'herbe vomissent la
même études montrent que 90 % des chats
et mange de la verdure ne présente aucun
signe de malaise avant de se mettre à
monter autrement vie l'herbe à chat ne
servirait pas nécessairement à évacuer
ce que le Matou n'arrive pas à digérer
alors qu'elle est sont
apparemment tous les félins mange de
l'herbe même les tigres et les lions
d'après les scientifiques c'est Vegeto
protégerai le système digestif du chat
il lui permettrait de lutter contre la
prolifération de certains parasites une
sorte de vermifuge naturel
c'est vrai qu'un chat est capable de
manger tout et n'importe quoi et pour
cela il ne se sert pas que de ses dents
sa langue lui est aussi très utile si
vous avez un chat vous l'avez sûrement
déjà constaté quand il vous lèche les
rappeuses
[Musique]
comme ça rappeuse comme une râpe à
fromage elle est recouverte de papilles
légèrement recourbé est solide et son
fait constitué de kératine comme nos
ongles elles sont beaucoup plus efficace
qu'une brosse pour défaire les nœud pour
retirer les saletés qui sont coincés
dans la fourrure et comme elles sont
recourbées est solide elle lui permet de
retirer tous les petits lambeaux de
chair qui sont restés collé au zoo de
c'est froid je comprends un peu mieux
pourquoi ne laisse rien dans sa gamelle
salon lui permet aussi de se rafraîchir
les chats comme les chiens d'ailleurs ne
transpire pas sauf au niveau des
coussinets ce qui est un peu juste quand
il fait chaud les papilles sont
recourbées mais aussi une forme concave
un peu comme cette feuille qui retient
l'eau en faisant sa toilette le chat
dépose donc une petite pellicule de
salive sur sa peau qui ont s'évapore de
la chaleur dans son organisme ce qui lui
permettrait de faire diminuer sa
température d'environ 1 degrés
mais trop trop
trop trop
est-ce que tu te caches
désolé elle adore jouer au chat et à la
souris bon bah à très bientôt et d'ici
là j'espère que j'aurai retrouvé nitro
[Applaudissements]